President Trump said last night that he
and Republican leaders will consider
regulating bump stocks
authorities say the Las Vegas gunman
used one of those devices to make
semi-automatic rifles shoot like fully
automatic weapons even the National
Rifle Association says it may accept the
new restrictions Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the latest on this
story Nancy good morning most people
didn't even know what a bump stock was
until the other day right and it's now a
bit disorienting to have Democrats
Republicans the White House and the NRA
all on the same side on a gun issue the
big question now is what's the best way
to restrict these devices and could
politics still get in the way the White
House says it wants to be part of the
discussion as a bipartisan effort to
limit bump stocks gains traction was it
a regulatory misstep by ATF some number
of years ago the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms determined in 2010
and again in 2012 that bump stocks are a
firearm part and therefore not subject
to tough thirty-year-old restrictions on
automatic weapons so here's the ATF
letter it shows that the bump fire stock
is in fact illegal until this week bump
stocks were available online for as
little as $100 on sites like gun broker
calm now the site lists devices for
$1000 or more I'm concerned that now
you're gonna have a massive
proliferation especially with copycat
type people congressman Adam Kinzinger
and other Republicans sent a letter to
the ATF Wednesday urging it to
re-evaluate these devices already too
large bump stock makers have had to
temporarily suspend taking new orders
due to extremely high demands Democrats
argue the best way to get rid of the
devices is with legislation there are
going to be Republicans who resist this
they're going to say if you give them
boom stock it's gonna be a slippery
slope I certainly hope so Democratic
Leader Nancy Pelosi's comments did not
go unnoticed by GOP lawmakers including
Steve Scalise who was shot this summer
but continues to be a fierce advocate
for gun rights she wants it to be a
slippery slope she doesn't want to stop
at pump stocks they want to go out and
limit the rights of gun owners in an
unexpected statement on Thursday the
National Rifle Association said that
bump stocks should be subject to
additional regulations but the gun
rights group and many Republican
lawmakers would rather have this
addressed by the ATF then get dragged
into a tricky gun safety discussion here
on Capitol Hill
Yael all right Thank You Nancy Sunday on
Face the Nation John Dickerson speaks
with NRA executive vice president Wayne
LaPierre Plus Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein who's sponsoring a bill to ban
the sale of bumped stocks that's Sunday
right here on CBS